et françois baroin bien sûr commencer
par cette intervention des manuels macro
hier soir est ce que pour vous le chef
de l'état a réussi à donner un cap et de
la clarté
je pense que le point le plus important
c'est d'abord la réussite du confinement
et qui fait que aujourd'hui l'ouverture
d'un certain nombre d'activités
professionnelles est possible et décidée
par le chef de l'état dont c'est la
responsabilité je rappelle que la
protection contre des épidémies c'est
l'état les maires sont des agents de
l'état dans un certain nombre de mesures
nous avions alerté sur les
problématiques d'une équité concernant
le commerce se sera rouvert à la fin de
la semaine
ça va dans la bonne direction nous
avions alerté sur la possibilité de
territorialiser un certain nombre de
mesures
là il faut qu'on en discute je pense
qu'il ya quand même une question sur les
restaurants la perspective lointaine du
mois de janvier doit peut-être amené
quand même à réfléchir à ce qu'on ne
peut pas imaginer baisser les jo des
restaurants de manière obligatoire -20
-30 % réorganiser enfin voila je pense
qu'avoir ou sur la aussi en faisant de
la dentelle embarras et je pense que là
il faut être pragmatique il faut voir la
circulation du virus le caractère
évolutif de l'épidémie le cadre
structurant mais quand même nos
restaurateurs nous interroger tous les
maires de france ils sont d'abord en
rang 1 sur la priorité concernant la
santé des français ils sont tous côtés
de l'état et aux côtés du président de
la république pour garantir cette
protection contre le virus mais il ya
aussi des enjeux de perspectives on va
avoir une casse économique et social qui
est très lourd donc je pense que sur les
restaurateurs tout comme sur les
commerces ou moment de la danse du
confinement
il faudra discuter en tout cas nous on
est disponible pour voir de quelle
manière on peut dire que le tout comme
vous avez écrit sur les commerces à jean
castex vous allez aussi porter non par
leur arrière je vous verra sûrement leur
origine dans les restos on verra
sûrement le projet nice dans les ceux
dont les jours dans les jours qui
viennent il faudra en discuter
c'est très très lointain le 20 janvier
je pensais beaucoup de restaurants qui
vont fermer mais fermé la porte faire
faillite et puis peut-être ouvrir ou pas
des activités plus tard mais ça c'est
quand même un grand sujet de
préoccupation
et voilà c'est trouver le bon équilibre
c'est ça qui est difficile elle est
difficile la gestion pour le chef de
l'état et la difficile elle est
difficile pour tous les pays confrontés
à cette épidémie
donc il faut être parlé avec humilité
avec prudence et avec distance mais avec
sens des responsabilités et le sens des
responsabilités c'est trouver le juste
équilibre entre quelles sont les bonnes
mesures pour protéger contre le virus et
qu'elle soit aussi les bonnes mesures
équilibrées qui permettent de s'adapter
à la présence du virus sans faire
prendre de risque mais en maintenant une
activité professionnelle je pense que
sur les restaurants c'est comme pour les
petits commerces il faudrait en discuter
et sur la réouverture des stations de
ski il s'est montré assez réservé sur la
période de noël vous en pensez quoi ce
choix je n'ai pas accès à toutes les
informations dont ils disposent jeu on
peut imaginer comprendre que quand il
fait moins 10 - 15 pendant noël et que
les restaurants les bars tout et tout
part en réalité de sa décision de fermer
les bars et les restaurants jusqu'à
jusqu'au mois de janvier donc ça veut
dire qu'il enjambe la période de noël
donc ça veut dire que c'est quasiment
impossible à partir du moment où ferme
jusqu'à janvier les restaurants et les
bars de créer les conditions d'une
ouverture des stations de ski est là
s'inquiète beaucoup de maires
naturellement tous les élus de montagne
nous ont déjà alerté et c'est assez
normal alors la neige est en train
d'arriver elle va arriver c'est pas la
partie la plus importante de la réalité
de le chiffre économique mais je
rappelle quand même que le virus
quantité est arrivé à amputer de l'ordre
d'un milliard et demi à presque 2
milliards les recettes des stations de
ski
au moment de la saison dernière donc ça
plus ça c'est des investissements très
lourds
si c'est cette décision au nom de la
protection des français contre le
développement du virus
alors dans ce cas là il faut des mesures
économiques plus forte et là il ya un
sujet sur les mesures économiques les
prêts garantis par l'état
c'est une bombe à retardement réalité
puisque on reporte le problème je pense
qu'il faut que l'état prenne à bras le
corps cette problématique s'il veut
maintenir et si nous souhaitons
maintenir un tissu économique dans nos
territoires d'accepter de dire c'est une
forme de dette était un éternel ou
perpétuelle vous rembourserai sur 15 ans
sur 20 ans
l'effort produit sur les 10 % + 20 % du
chiffre d'affaires pour colmater les
brèches pour le petit commerce doit être
également produit sur les prêts garantis
par l'état c'est pas durable pouvez pas
demander à une entreprise aujourd'hui
d'avaler tout son cash flow pour
rembourser les prêts que l'état lui a
donné au moment du coc vide et au bout
de cinq ans il a le rendez vous avec la
mort il faut intégrer cette perspective
il faut intégrer ce moyen terme et il
faut prendre des mesures plus
importantes et plus rassurante qui
permettrait de dire
puisque le président de la république a
dit au départ quoi qu'il en coûte le
quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est une dette perpétuelle que l'état
apporte au tissu économique pour
permettre la durée et le maintien ou
survie de ces activités mais il peut
aller jusqu'où ce quoi qu'il en coûte
françois warrants vous avez été un voix
bercy en aujourd'hui avec une dette de
120 % en déficit de + 10 % pour vous on
va jusqu'où avec ce quoi qu'il en coûte
est ce que là aussi a pas un risque pour
l'avenir
j'ai été l'un des négociateurs français
du traité budgétaire et j'ai tiré un
certain nombre de leçons de ces
expériences
les réductions de dépenses très rapide
avec des augmentations d'impôts c'est un
effet récessif et nous avons
probablement était très ambitieux de
fixer les 3% de déficit en 2013 tout ça
a volé en éclats et il n'y a plus eu ces
problèmes-là la banque centrale
européenne rachète toutes les dettes a
racheté toutes les dates émises par
l'italie toutes les dettes émises par la
france
la banque centrale européenne qui est en
fait la clé la pierre angulaire du
dispositif qui permet aux gens de
comprendre pourquoi on peut faire de la
dette comme ça pour rien c'est que la
banque centrale européenne fait son
travail
jusqu'où on peut aller jusqu'à ce que
l'europe qui va émettre en début d'année
prochaine 750 milliards sur les marchés
c'est du jamais vu et qui rachète
également tous les titres des grandes
entreprises fait que elle va continuer
en fonction de la volonté des pays a
racheté ses dettes
donc si la france dit nous intégrons une
part durable dans nos comptes sur les
prêts garantis par l'état pour aider nos
entreprises à survivre ce sera une
émission d'obligations du trésor pour
financer une partie de cet emprunt et la
banque centrale européenne ou les
rachètera donc c'est possible
donc il ya un chemin pour le faire ça
veut dire que pour vous l'adage la dette
d'aujourd'hui sont les impôts de demain
à priori ne pourraient ne pas se
réaliser
bon alors ça ça veut dire qu'on tue la
génération qui vient serge sais pas si
vous avez des enfants en tout cas ça
veut dire que vos enfants ils auront
quasiment plus de services publics ils
auront un à un ils seront accablé nabot
c'est impossible
cette question de la dette du coc vide
est une question qui va couvrir
plusieurs générations vous savez par
exemple que hollande qui était un pays
qui était appuyée sur des marais pour
assécher ses marais construire ce pays
ils ont fait une dette ou 7e siècle
quelque chose comme ça qu'ils continuent
de rembourser donc une dette perpétuelle
c'est possible ça veut dire qu'on
remboursent uniquement les intérêts et
le capital sont détaillées sur cinq ans
4 50 ans 80 en un siècle c'est possible
donc il faut aussi être mesuré rassurant
sur ce sujet en tout cas ça ne peut pas
se traduire par des impôts ont déjà
numéro 1 sur les prélèvements
obligatoires
il faut plutôt imaginer comment relancer
l'activité économique par une baisse de
la fiscalité que augmenter les taxes et
des impôts pour la suite c'est ce qu'il
restera d'activité on va parler d'un
autre sujet évoqué par emmanuel macron
hier celle isolement des personnes
contaminées
oui deux sujets qui est qui et
réveilleront en effet président de la
mfr en vous puisque vous avez critiqué
la verticalité du pouvoir sur la
question de la crise sanitaire
là il ya deux annonces qui qui vous met
en jeu si je puis dire c'est l'isolément
des personnes malades puisque le
président a voulu interpeller le
gouvernement et le parlement pour
imaginer des mesures plus contraignantes
et veut s'appuyer sur les mers aussi
pour l'aider en ce sens et puis il ya la
question de la vaccination vous aviez
dit à olivier derand le ministre de la
santé que vous n'avez on n'avait pas le
droit à l'erreur
est-ce que là vous comment vous situez
par rapport à ces deux questions
il faut on peut avoir un bref recul sur
ce qui s'est fait sur les deux périodes
de confinement la première partie de
confinement a montré une défaillance de
l'état pour ne pas dire un effondrement
de l'état sur la logistique la bataille
de la logistique a été perdue qu'il a
colmaté les entreprises qui ont été très
remarquable et très véloce les
collectivités locales des régions les
départements les communes les
intercommunalités qui ont achetés les
masques proximité qui ont assuré le show
l'acheminement et l'état a été incapable
de répondre à cette dernière qui est ce
dernier kilomètre l'état était très
centralisé en silo avec le ministère de
la santé
une lecture hospital au centre et alors
que 98% des soins se fait par la
médecine de ville et par le privé donc
il ya un problème culturel il faut en
tirer les leçons
une commission denquête au sénat une
commission denquête à l'assemblée nous y
avons répondu nous avons apporté notre
témoignage et et je pense qu'il y aura
des leçons à tirer de tout cela sur les
tests même motif même punition si j'ose
dire ça a été très aléatoire au départ
et si les collectivités les maires
n'avaient pas été au rendez vous
notamment durant l'été pour anticiper
avoir quinze jours d'avancé sur la
possibilité de savoir qui était
contaminée qui n'étaient pas l'état
n'aurait pas été en situation de le
faire la vaccination sera la même chose
et il faut naturellement anticipé nous
écrivions nous écrivons d'ailleurs ce
jour territoire unis c'est à dire le
président des régions
de france renaud muselier le président
départements de france 2 minibus ou et
moi même titre de la nef au premier
ministre pour lui demander d'organiser
un tour de table sur l'organisation de
la campagne de vaccination sur la
problématique que vous évoquez si j'ai
bien compris qui est une initiative de
membres de la majorité à travers une ppl
sur le tester tracé isolé protéger
protéger isolé effectivement c'était le
terme vergine mais le régime chinois est
pas tout à fait de la même nature que
celui que nous vivons est d'une certaine
manière forte heureusement pour autant
cette problématique elle pour une vraie
question c'est que si on indemnise comme
si c'était une maladie classique
traditionnelle ce qui semble être le
chemin proposé par les parlementaires
et si on met en place un dispositif
d'accompagnement de lmr serait
naturellement disponible pour apporter
l'alimentation trouver des partenariats
avec des associations prodiguer les
soins faire un lien avec la médecine de
ville très bien derrière est-ce que vous
pensez que les gens vont continuer à se
tester si leur emploi est en jeu si la
survie de l'entreprise la petite pme ou
de tpe dans laquelle il travaille j'ai
bien peur qu'il y ait un effet boomerang
qui soit dangereux donc je pense qu'il
faut pas se hâter trop vite sur ce
terrain là un dernier mot sur la
vaccination il dit pas de vaccination
obligatoire le chef de l'état vous êtes
aussi sur cette position par d'avoir on
voit bien les réserves qui existe dans
notre pays sur la vaccination en général
et sur celle ci en particulier les
interrogations sur la nature du vaccin
quel vaccin d'où vient-il quel est il
est-ce que c'est scouting dans les airs
russes ou est ce que c'est la puissance
américaine en partenariat l'annnonce du
calendrier très rapide par le président
de la république est une information qui
va quand même dans le sens progressif
d'une normalisation des relations
sociales à terme
donc c'est vrai que la campagne de
vaccination la pédagogie pour le plus
grand nombre la communication le plus
large
la protection des publics les plus
fragiles c'est quelque chose pour
lesquels les maires seront à la
disposition de l'état pour favoriser
cette campagne mais la rendre
obligatoire
compte tenu des réserves des
incertitudes et du cadre général de la
rapidité avec laquelle ces vaccins ont
été effectuées
justifie naturellement qu'on puisse pas
rendre obligatoire vaccin ça vous feriez
vaccinés s'ils étaient disponibles pour
vous en janvier
alors moi j'ai un problème c'est que je
suis hypocondriaque donc je me méfie
tout y compris des vacances va continuer
à parler de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
on va aller du côté de canal 32 c'est
votre télévision locale françois baroin
il est une question pour vous d'aurélie
juigné de canal 32 à propos de cette
gestion de la crise sanitaire
bonjour françois baroin une question de
la part de la rédaction de canal 32 en
tant que maire estimez-vous avoir eu
assez de pouvoir assez de poids pour
gérer la crise sanitaire et économique
au niveau local on sait qu'à 3 vous avez
rendu le port du masque obligatoire dans
le centre-ville vous avez demandé et
obtenu le soutien logistique des
militaires aménager des lieux de
dépistage kobe 19 ou encore allouer des
aides pour les entreprises
est ce que vous auriez aimé pouvoir en
faire plus c'est ce que les maires
devraient selon vous avoir plus de
latitude pour gérer ce type de crise ou
à l inverse considérez vous que l'état
aurait dû être plus présent à vos côtés
pour soutenir les collectivités locales
je pense que les deux on aurait aimé
avoir plus de latitudes plus de moyens
mais je rappelle au fond deux idées
simples
la santé est une prérogative de l'état
c'est à l'état qu'il appartient de
garantie à la protection de sa
population contre le développement d'une
épidémie quelle qu'elle soit les maires
n'ont pas de compétences en matière de
santé donc nous agissons en général
comme des agents de l'état au service de
la mise en oeuvre de décisions qui ne
sont pas les nôtres
deuxièmement nous vivons sous un régime
juridique très particulier qui est un
état d'urgence sanitaire qui est inédit
espèces d'articles 16 de la constitution
appliquée à la santé publique et qui a
réduit très significativement les
pouvoirs de police propre du maire y
compris en matière de police donc là
aussi nous avons eu nos pouvoirs réduits
pour autant
au début nous avons fait preuve
d'agilité mais nous avons été contraints
par des décisions
j'ai en tête l'initiative du maire de
sceaux secrétaire-général par ailleurs
de l'association des maires de france
qui avait imposé de manière obligatoire
le port d'un tissu ou d'un masque à
l'époque dans sa ville le conseil d'état
dit c'est pas possible parce que ça
n'est pas compatible avec l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
si les décisions vont dans la bonne
direction ça pose pas de problème mais
je pense que on peut imaginer quand même
sortir assez rapidement de ce système
d'état d'urgence sanitaire je pense que
ça s'est il appartient au parlement
d'être très vigilants et très attentif
ça pose un problème quand même de
libertés publiques en général et ça pose
un problème de coordination de liberté
ou de libre administration des
collectivités territoriales et rendre
compatible dans la durée un système que
celui ci à mon avis est quelque chose
qu'il faut regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention
ensuite est ce que l'on aurait aimé que
l'état soit plus à nos côtés franchement
ça s'est bien rapproché avec les préfets
de département je l'avais demandé à
l'époque à monsieur castex qui était le
monsieur confinement nous étions à
l'origine d'une certaine manière de
cette idée de redonner le pouvoir aux
préfets de département bassin de vie
pertinents ils ont des moyens ça n'a pas
été le cas avec les ars en tout cas
inégalement répartie selon les
territoires
mais là c'est le problème du ministère
de la santé qui est en silo même un prêt
faire du mal à discuter parfois avec les
agressent ça va mieux parce que
l'urgence de la situation amène à
discuter mais il ya quand même des
grandes leçons à tirer toute cette il
faut les réformes et les agences
régionales de santé
oui je penche pour ce qu'il faut que le
président du conseil régional et le
préfet de région soit coprésident des
ars à l'échelle régionale je pense que
tout le médico social doit aller sous
l'autorité du président de département
je pense qu'il faut modifier les
conseils de surveillance des hôpitaux
pour que le maire soit à la tête d'une
administration d'un hôpital qu'il puisse
écrire avec les professionnels les plans
de développement d'établissements le
plan d'investissement de chacun des
investissements que le maire soit au
coeur du dispositif du rapprochement
entre le public et le privé qu'il soit
un acteur majeur d'accompagnement du
développement de la médecine générale
qu'on puisse embaucher des médecins ont
bougé embaucher des sages-femmes des
infirmières et c'est pour ça que nous
avons une grande ambition d'une nouvelle
organisation des pouvoirs publics qui
toucherait la santé mais pas seulement
la santé ça peut aller sur le logement
le sport la culture le tourisme
beaucoup de sujets doivent être revus et
corrigés à la lumière de cette crise et
à la lumière de ces années qui montre
que l'état s'est totalement désengagé
dans les territoires et il est tellement
obèses au niveau parisien qu'il ya un
déséquilibre pour tout le monde y
compris pour l'état lui-même
et sur cette crise qui s'aggrave à ce
qu'elle aggrave pour vous la fracture
sociale la fracture territoriale et est
ce que vous redoutez un mouvement de
colère qui peut aller jusqu'au bout pour
vous grande colère on ne le sait pas ce
que l'on voit en tout cas sur le terrain
c'est les plans sociaux qui s'annonce
sur les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire ou sur les petites et
moyennes entreprises
on voit bien qu'un certain nombre
d'entreprises ne vont pas résisté à la
double lame du premier confinement et du
second confinement le temps des
procédures vous aurez un rendez-vous
estimatif est précis du nombre de
chômeurs que aura eu cette crise dans
notre pays
à la sortie du printemps mois de mai au
mois de juin
ensuite l'été va passer et puis il y
aura un nouveau temps avec des
revendications la colère qu'elle prend
peut-elle prendre je n'en sais rien il
ya une fracture territoriale qui s'est
aggravée aussi avec cette crise pour
vous alors elle s'est en tout cas elle a
été mise en lumière de façon
spectaculaire là où il y avait un retard
sur le numérique là où les hôpitaux
n'étaient pas accolé à une fac de
médecine c'est à dire clairement si vous
êtes chu vous êtes à mieux un peu mieux
protégés si vous n'êtes pas vous êtes un
peu moins bien protégés la
désorganisation complète de dispositifs
amené beaucoup de maires beaucoup d'élus
a complété à boucher les trous et
d'ailleurs vous avez des études de
francs stratégie qui montre bien que sur
toute la façade ont globalement qui va
du nord de l'île jusqu'au nord de
bordeaux toute cette grande langue en
quelque sorte a vu une désertification
ou unes des implications très nettes de
l'état d'en cesser ses effectifs ses
moyens et c'est là où les collectivités
locales on compensait largement la
défaillance de l'état
ce désengagement de l'état vous le
critiquez sûr d'un point de vue
financier
hier vous aviez votre conférence de
presse du congrès des maires
dématérialisée pour une grande partie
vous avez parce que c'est important
d'expliquer pour poursuivre aujourd'hui
ses grilles normalement c'est la semaine
du congrès des maires
tout à fait il pour la première fois en
dehors des périodes de guerre nous ont
pris une décision qui était d'annuler le
congrès des maires mais de maintenir une
présence d'expression publique pour
éclairer l'opinion publique sur les
débats que nous avons avec l'état nous
sommes en guerre sani et merci au public
ses mains d'hommes la trup un relais
précieux de ces débats vous avez demandé
une nationalisation des
des pertes de recettes enregistrées
durant cette crise sanitaire qu'est ce
que vous entendez par là c'est très
simple on a évoqué la question de la
dette et on n'a bloqué que ça posait pas
de problème je rappelle que la france
est aujourd'hui le premier émetteur au
monde de 170 milliards autour de 270
milliards cette année
globalement si on globalise les deux
vagues de confinement l'effet de ciseau
entre les recettes qui ne rentrent pas
dans les caisses des communes ou des
intercommunalités si on prend ce bloc là
et est évidemment les mesures de
dépenses supplémentaires qui ont été
affectés nous avons autour de 15
milliards pour les communes les
intercommunalités les départements les
régions
la deuxième vague on peut pas encore
l'estimé mais on peut imaginer qu'on va
se rapprocher d'un point de pib
qu'est ce que ça pouvait faire pour
l'état de négocier une émission
d'emprunts supplémentaires et challes
hauteur d'un point de pipe qui nous
garantissait la totalité de nos recettes
et l'état négocier avec bruxelles
ce dispositif qu'est ce que ça pouvait
faire d'être à 117 118 119 et de passer
à 120 on sera à 124 125 avec un niveau
de déficit tout à fait excessif en faire
une fois qu'ils ont un rebond économique
ça reviendra et puis l'état négociera
cela on a des très bons gestionnaires de
notre dette c'est ça que nous avons
demandé et la nationalisation des pertes
de recettes
ça veut dire ça ça veut dire l'état
prend à sa charge cette problématique
des administrations publiques locales et
porte pour les administrations publiques
locales
le cadre général des émissions de dette
par rapport à nos besoins
cela aurait évité quoi c'est cette
suradministration ces débats que nous
avons ces anticipations sur des
difficultés supplémentaires avec la
suppression des impôts de production que
nous contestons car tout comme nous
avons contesté la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation qui n'est pas une
suppression d'un impôt pour les gens qui
est une nationalisation du contribuable
c'est plus le contribuable local qui
payent la taxe d'habitation c'est le
contribuable national qui paye ou ses
successeurs
parce que c'est du déficit un impôt qui
crée un lien entre le territoire et son
habitant les impôts de production
c'était le lien entre l'agent économique
et son territoire l'état au nom de la
crise doit faire un geste pour les
entreprises ils se trompent de cible et
j'ai dit que c'était une erreur
économique
parce qu'il nous dit c'est pour aider à
relativiser mais c'est pas des impôts de
production qui bloquent la rue de
localisation ces poids des charges
le poids des charges et 16 à 17% du pib
et donc c'est bien sûr sur les charges
qu'il fallait travailler les impôts de
production en prenant cette mesure
déstabilise les intercommunalités ne
nous garantit aucune recette puisque on
prend une référence justement qui sera
trop faible par rapport à nos besoins et
je vous l'annoncé et nous l'avons dit
hier à l'unisson toutes sensibilités
politiques confondues
l'association des maires elle rassemble
tout le monde toutes sensibilités
politiques
on laisse au vestiaire nos engagements
militants on se retrouve autour de la
table on discute on aura un problème
d'autofinancement l'autofinancement
c'est quoi c'est ce qui nous reste pour
avoir un effet de levier pour négocier
avec les banquiers investir l'état dit
la relance les 100 milliards ça va se
faire par de l'investissement public qui
porte l'investissement public en france
les collectivités locales à 70%
nous aurons du mal être au rendez-vous
de la relance par l'investissement à
raison justement d'une mauvaise approche
de la problématique de béthune où les
ags manquer puisque le projet de loi de
finances est actuellement en examen
c'est trop tard pour 2021
oui enfin on a alerté tout de suite très
vite très tôt ils n'ont pas voulu
l'entendre que son prix d'autres
décisions nous avons un désaccord qui
est réel qui est majeur qui manifestent
que nous évoquons à chacune des réunions
que nous ne manquerons aucune occasion
d'évoquer à l'avenir c'est une erreur et
ça nous met en difficulté et en nous
mettant en difficulté cela mettra en
difficulté la relance par
l'investissement public c'est à dire le
bâtiment les travaux publics je tiens
d'ailleurs après cette réunion une visio
avec les représentants du bâtiment au
niveau national pour expliquer la
situation et pour que nous fassions donc
en quelque sorte cause commune auprès de
l'état pour avancer sur ce sujet et un
mot sur la décentralisation et la
fameuse la 3d un jeu wii qui est tout
est toujours qu'on attend toujours ses
c1 c'est ce ram sera ne vois-tu rien
venir
a priori quand même en début d'année ça
devrait se décanter mais cela dit vous
avez critiqué une descente à une
recentralisation rampante
alors même que donc l'état s'apprête à
proposer cette loi 3d est-ce qu'il faut
déjà s'attendre à un échec
en tout cas ça ne s'annonce pas comme un
grand succès puisque ses ordres et
laignel premier vice-président de
2 de l'aef qui a trouvé une belle
formule quand on parle de 3d
s'agissant décentralisation avec ce
pouvoir ça manque de relief et c'est
vrai j'évoquais tools toutes les leçons
que nous devons tirer il faut le faire
de manière apaisée
je le dis aussi on n'est pas des
adversaires de laitages l'avait rappelé
j'ai été en responsabilité à bercy ou
dans d'autres ministères à l'intérieur
ou à l'outre-mer il n'y a pas plus
régaliens que ces ministères là et nous
aimons servir l'état mais mais mais on
est au rendez vous d'un constat
d'impuissance dans un cas et d'un besoin
immense de libertés locales de
respiration et d'organisation la nouveau
partage des responsabilités publiques ce
modèle là d'un état sur un ministre à
paris sur centralisée de surcroît dominé
par un courant politique qui pense que
en prenant ces décisions et en appuyant
sur un bouton ça descend directement sur
les territoires ça ne marche pas ça ne
marche pas depuis très nombreuses années
c'est une mauvaise compréhension du
fonctionnement en quelque sorte de
l'administration de notre pays il faut
avoir une grande ambition en matière de
décentralisation je les dis en matière
de santé je les dis sur le médico social
le logement
quel est le sens à donner à une apl qui
est du même niveau selon que vous
trouvez à neuilly à paris a3 ou dans une
ville qui à 70 % de logements sociaux
il faut décentraliser mais décentralisée
ça veut dire quoi ça venir doubler les
effectifs nous donner les moyens et
l'état ne s'en occupe plus nous nous en
occupons est bien mieux même chose sur
le tourisme même chose sur la culture
quels sont les acteurs qui finance la
culture et qui sera au rendez-vous de la
relance du du spectacle vivant du
financement des associations ce sont les
maires le sport qui finance les
complexes sportifs les piscines les
stades sont les maires qui finance les
associations sont les mères c'est plus
l'état donc il faut en tirer les
conséquences et avoir cette grande
ambition
on est à ce stade très loin de cette
grande ambition on dit oui mais s'avère
de la différenciation c'est déjà dans
les textes c'est bien ça va dans la
bonne direction il faut probablement
avoir plus de liberté
en fait on voit bien qu'avec le coe j la
différenciation aurait pu prendre la
forme de la territorialisation serre
l'adaptation des contraintes pour toute
une série d'activités économiques selon
la présence du virus
on n'a pas du tout parlé ça n'a pas du
tout été retenue on évoquait les
commerces on évoque aujourd'hui les
restaurants
alors on nous dit mais à des
concentrations et des concentrations ce
sera très bien si c'est dans la loi mais
il suffit que le premier ministre dix
les préfets aux autorités dans les
départements sur toutes les
administrations et l'affairé réglée et
l' affaire réglée parce que du coup avec
un peu plus d'effectifs
là où ils sont été réduit nous avons les
moyens d'avoir un état fort et les
maires sont en demande d'avoir un
interlocuteur fort puissant et qui lui
garantit le fait que lorsqu'il y à un
accord entre l'état et amer il y a la
certitude du chili françois baroin va
parler de la loi sécurité globale on va
parler de l'article 24 dans quelques
instants mais n'y a pas que ça dans
cette loi il ya notamment un article qui
étend les pouvoirs de la police
municipale est ce que vous êtes
favorable à ça on sera police municipale
la position des maires de france est
constante depuis de très nombreuses
années puisqu'il ya une récurrence
poussée de ses sujets c'est le maire qui
décide de présenter au conseil municipal
ou pas il décide il est libre la
création de la police
le la voilure de cette police municipale
la renommant naturellement c'est le
maire qui décide ensuite aller dans la
direction d'un partenariat entre la
nationale et la municipale pour
renforcer le rôle d'agent ou d'officier
de police judiciaire dans certaines
circonstances
ça va dans la bonne direction à la
condition que ce soit une faculté c'est
à dire c'est donc là encore le maire et
le conseil municipal qui décide
souverainement du cadre général d'emploi
des effectifs de la police municipale
sur l'armement il a été clair gérald
darmanin il a 17 au maire de décider
mais est-ce que déjà dans cette loi il
ya trop de décisions sur le rôle de la
police municipale est ce qu'elle va trop
loin pour vous non non je veux savoir
pourquoi il ya des polices municipales
c'est trop général parce que l'état
s'est désengagé dans sa police nationale
l'histoire elle est là et les preuves
les maires qui ont produit des efforts
financiers budgétaire important et aussi
d'accompagnement d'investissement dans
des centres de supervision urbaine ou
autre c'est en général là où
malheureusement l'état s'est désengagé
sauf que je rappelle que dans notre pays
les problématiques d'ordre public
c'est l'état on n'est pas aux états unis
1 le maire c'est pas un shérif sa police
municipale ne porte pas une étoile
l'ordre public c'est l'état la
tranquillité du voisinage
c'est le maire alors qu'il y à meilleur
partenariat dans des conventions signées
décider souverainement par l'instance
délibérante qui s'appelle le conseil
municipal
pour que dans certaines occasions il y
ait la possibilité de mettre les polices
municipales au service de la nationale
pour maîtriser l'ordre public oui mais
ça doit se faire sous le contrôle de la
police nationale mais on doit pas non
plus être là pour soulager totalement
les activités de la nationale et sur des
activités
je dirais de plein air donc ça il faudra
en discuter mais ça va plutôt dans la
bonne direction de renforcer le travail
entre la nationale et municipale et
l'article 24 mai 24 tant décrié qui est
qui encadre la diffusion de d'image des
forces de l'ordre vous en pensez quoi
moi je suis un ancien journaliste donc
je suis très très attaché à une liberté
fondamentale qui est la capacité en tout
en tous lieux et toutes circonstances
pour un journaliste de faire son travail
et d'éclairer l'opinion publique sur ce
qui se passe je suis un ancien ministre
de l'intérieur et je suis d'une famille
de policiers et j'ai une passion immense
une admiration sans limites pour le
courage de ces hommes avec peu de
formations qui font un travail
remarquable au service de la protection
de nos de liberté et c'est là où le
parlementaire son honneur et sa dignité
c'est trouver le juste équilibre entre
la garantie de ses libertés
fondamentales et la protection naturelle
des policiers qui ne demande pas à avoir
des droits exorbitants du droit commun
ils ne le demande pas en plus ils
veulent juste pouvoir dans l'exercice de
leurs missions être protégé par l'état
et juste pouvoir rentrer chez eux sans
avoir à subir de craintes pour leur
famille et donc là nous devons aussi
aller sur le terrain n'a renforcement et
d'une écoute supérieur est clairement
c'est vraiment notre a été trouvé dans
ce qui a été voté à l'assemblée où il
faut leur travail et la définition
juridique de malveillant elle nécessite
certainement pour le sénat puisque le
texte viendra ici d'être retravaillé la
malveillance elle est très subjective
pour certains c'est bienveillant de
montrer des images pour d'autres c'est
malveillant donc pense que
l'interprétation juridique peut pas être
uniquement laisser à la main des
tribunaux le premier parlementaire le
premier ministre il a eu raison de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel sur
cette question on verra en tout cas quoi
le conseil constitué sûrement que
c'est quand même la cour qui est chargée
de garantir l'exercice de la loi
fondamentale et dans notre loi
fondamentale dans notre coin suprême et
l équilibre de ses libertés
fondamentales
c'est pas un petit sujet c'est pas un
sujet médiocre un mot sur la loi
séparatisme bien oui autres grands
textes qui va arriver le au mois de
décembre dans la cette loi alors dit
confortant les principes républicains
bien sûr l'article de prêt permet au
préfet de saisir la justice s'ils
considèrent qu'une décision d'une
collectivité territoriale je le cite un
est de nature à porter gravement
atteinte au principe de neutralité des
services publics
hier j'ai cru comprendre que vous ont
dénoncé un peu la main mise sous jacente
de l'état sur les communes
salut pour il faut absolument que le
parlement corrige ce texte il ne va pas
dans la bonne direction d'abord
puisqu'elle est le maire objectivement
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
issu des élections qui va être un acteur
de la déstabilisation des valeurs de la
république qu'il est censé faire
respecter est pas un maire aujourd'hui
et la mfr été aux avant postes de cette
problématique de la laïcité et si vous
le permettez je l'étais moi même il ya
une quinzaine d'années puisque j'étais
l'auteur d'un rapport qui a créé les
conditions sous l'autorité de la
présidence de jacques chirac de
l'interdiction du voile et des signes
religieux à l'école et il était temps
les maires seront les garants de la
laïcité dans sa valeur son expression et
dans l'application de ces règles est
pourquoi nous pouvons pas accepter
un article de cette nature s'il n'est
pas corrigée c'est tout simplement parce
que ça redonne des pouvoirs à l'état et
ça nous en enlève alors que nous sommes
des acteurs qui sont beaucoup plus
efficaces que l'état pour justement
faire vivre ces règles de laïcité
notamment dans les tissus associatif
notamment dans les complexes sportifs
notamment dans les piscines et notamment
dans un sujet que j'aimerais avoir
discuté par le parlement qui est la
définition d'un espace du service public
élargir une reconquête territoriales qui
fait qu'on peut dire l'espace
l'association la subvention et les gens
qui sont sont chargées de faire
respecter cette règle de la laïcité donc
c'est un tout donc oui nous avons une
position plus que réservé on va le dire
poliment sur certains articles de mêlée
mais rompt-il espèces suffisamment usage
de surveillance autour de autour de
saskia pas eu des failles des failles il
y en a sûrement mais une fois encore les
problèmes que nous évoquons et qui
aboutissent au drame que nous avons vécu
très récemment où il y a quelques années
avec la menace permanente qui existe
c'est de l'ordre public c'est même de la
surveillance générale c'est de la
sécurité du territoire
les files sont d'abord et avant tout
c'est pour l'association c'est on sait
combien ça peu comment ça peut se passer
aussi mais oui oui ça il faut avancer
sur ce terrain là nous avons des
propositions des propositions de
formation obligatoire des responsables
associatifs de surveillance de ce qui
s'y passe d'engagement la responsabilité
des représentants associatifs qui
touchent des subventions et la
possibilité avec des rendez vous deux
fois par an par exemple de supprimer la
subvention est donc de mettre
l'association au pied du mur de ses
responsabilités avant de se quitter
françois baroin on va écouter le
secrétaire général de votre parti et les
républicains aurélien pradié c'était il
ya quinze jours sur notre antenne je dis
simplement que jusque là mon candidat a
été françois baroin et que j'ai une
forme de décence de ne pas être la
mouche qui change de deux bêtes en
l'espace de mais c'est fini françois
baroin on m'a toujours dit qu'en
politique comme en amour il y avait une
phrase qui va aller il ne faut jamais
dire jamais et jamais dire toujours
il a encore raison d'espérer ayant
prédit l est pas prise
alors je vous rappelle que nous sommes
dans spes de congrès des maires vitres
virtuel et je suis naturellement pas
venu
si avec vous répondent à votre
invitation pour répondre à cette
question chez venu pour mettre en place
les perspectives d'une en allemand et on
en a bien sûr langue et cela comprendra
pas mais ça ne me surprend pas de cette
décision est prise ou pas même si vous
ne nous a donnés je ne vous répond
[Musique]